we should put this on jk news this is
good i love this game
really cool
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up jk park people i'm so happy to
be back
in the hosting seat i know it's been a
few years and it feels like my old home
again
i also want to say thank you to you guys
specifically you
right there yeah you thank you thank you
for keeping us alive without you we are
[ __ ] pixie dust we're not here
anymore
all right so if you notice all around me
i have barbell brigade i have nothing
but attractive uh asian men
and very buff brothers
and today because we have so many asian
men we're going to be playing
raining asian men hallelujah it's
raining
we're going to be playing agree or
disagree asian
man edition so everything that i'm going
to ask you all these statements that i'm
going to be giving
are going to be around asian so we're
speaking for the whole world on this one
absolutely all the asians i love that i
love representing
asian men oh the asian i love having
that on my shoulder too i gotta
represent i've always wanted to
represent monk
okay so i'm going nice i'm gonna pass
out some note
pads and this is where you're gonna
write if you agree or disagree
don't worry about the colors the colors
the yellow one i knew it i
knew it was the goddamn i got the yellow
one
okay so i'm going to give you a
statement we're going to do a little
practice round okay i missed these
okay i would prefer if you guys can
write a big boost
oh can you buy me one of these later yes
you you can have it should we just
already write an agreed or disagree why
do i feel like a teacher
yo you're not real asian if you don't
remember this [ __ ] right here
oh [ __ ] your little ass do your last one
i thought you were going to write the z
with the like the old school
symbol backwards yeah got rice it's the
a-z
end yeah something [ __ ] the rest can't
say that word
no okay okay so we're gonna do a quick
little sample round okay so that
everyone's on the exact same page are
you here with me yeah i'm here okay
okay so this is a sample okay so agree
you're gonna write down agree or
disagree
i like hot dogs more than
pizza agree or disagree
ready three two one i went backwards
disagree what the [ __ ] jumps off what
does that mean
agree you cheated agree disagree
disagree okay
so why do you disagree that hot dogs
are uh that you like hot dogs more than
pizza i
don't like hot dogs more than pizza
because hot dogs are harder to identify
as far as what the meat is comprised of
pizza you already know the ingredients
science
very science all right so we get it are
we all good yeah well that was a
practice round that was
what the [ __ ] did i say for the past
five minutes so how many points
is
all right so we're not we're not we're
not in our class part
what i'm getting ready let me help you
nothing okay
so now we're going to jump into the game
ready this is a sick ass game
are you being sarcastic no i like it i
think i should i think we should have
done this on just kidding news
okay cool it's kind of like a bootleg
version of the [ __ ] like what jubilee
project does
no one's drawing a dick everyone else is
i didn't hear what you said but i think
it was good thank you here we go
okay being with an abg was
one of my top goals when i was
younger uh for those of you that do not
know or are familiar with an abg
it's an asian baby girl and how would
you define an asian baby girl
uh lip gloss yeah falsies um
like this probably blonde hair screaming
like little x-wing stuff
yeah we're a fast writer wow okay
everyone got their answers cool i'm
gonna count down
and then we all show the camera ready
three two
one okay we gotta agree and i didn't
agree
agree disagree
[Laughter]
yeah that was your guys's goal dude yes
wait you said when we were young
yeah all the hottest girls on import
tuner
yes every [ __ ] asian dude was like
salivating or the girls
elevating is a very pc way to say the
girls on the flyers
on the little cardboard flyer party
flyers oh
do you guys remember the remix girls yes
what's that they're twins wait don't
tell me like i know
and francine d that's when she was like
the queen of all abgs
i loved her so much like import tuner
cover girl remember more
yeah uh you said disagree why i just
didn't grow up with a lot of
i didn't like where did you grow up i
grew up pasadena i didn't i didn't
there's a lot of asian people
not the schools i went for pasadena is a
different world i wasn't i didn't know a
lot of asian girls yeah so you
that wasn't your life goal do you did
you know what an abg was also not a
different generation not until you guys
saw
different generations like 21. no i'm
not bro how are you
28. how old are you 37 you
34. you 37. guys
okay we're the same
age yeah that's why i didn't ask you can
we explain what an abg is you don't even
know what a magazine is
yeah what is that important
what is that you put it in a gun import
models
okay do we have i don't know because it
changed abg changed over time didn't it
now uh i don't even know what it is now
so do you know those asian girls that
work at the
vietnamese coffee shops you guys say it
i'm like oh i know what you mean
but like when you guys said asian uh abg
someone told me it was asian boba girl
that's what i
ever see
i don't even know if we had boba like
that back then yeah see so one wasn't
asian bubbles they were like
bell bottoms this is what i heard like
in the past year that's pretty good
remember the bell bottom
our era the one in front of the you need
the honda honda civics
integra honda civics i think back then
even the abg's didn't have fake boobs
yet no no no they were
they were all natural dude but they had
pagers they had
pagers very similar and we spoke pager
code back then
one four three six three seven nine nine
toyota celica ready
zero seven seven three four abg right
here okay next statement
ready yeah comedy featuring
asian stereotypes is hilarious
so write down if you agree or disagree
i didn't come up with any of these
disclaimer
i don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] or [ __ ]
about [ __ ]
all right good comedy ready yup three
two one reveal your answers agree agree
agree agree agree
if done well if you've done well
well uh give me an example of it being
done well and then one being
jk films was done asian
also i always say like the more accurate
yeah
the the cult like if you're laughing
with the culture
and you know these inside jokes that's
like appreciation
yeah but then when you're just making up
[ __ ] like
chinch you know [ __ ] it i like to eat
iguana
chinchon it's making him laugh well
because he's doing it good
he does it way better dude jk films
doing it well he do well good
well good time you know like someone
that's still doing it this day is joe
coy and he's crushing it he
is oh yeah he does really well it's
really good sometimes i even get
offended for it wow
i'm just like yo that's just [ __ ]
stupid it's offensive but it's too easy
when it's too easy offensive
yeah it's got to be smart comedy but you
know this like since we're all boomers
and [ __ ] like this new
generation this like no like okay sorry
we're we're
from the great depression era but then
these
but the uh these like like this new new
generation
they think no stereotypical jokes
is ever funny at any time well no one
thinks any jokes are funny right now
and you see i pointed the guns this way
because i i don't know
well that means i got shot well then i
was this way
okay bart are you i feel like you're
drawing again no he's not i'm not
what how does it know is it isn't it
i don't know how to do it oh okay i said
it a lot all right next statement
i am more turned on when i see porn
featuring
an asian man or woman versus
porn without asians agree or disagree
we say that again please you can't throw
the ore women in there that's really
difficult i didn't write this dude okay
fine
i am more turned on when i see porn
featuring an asian man
or woman versus porn without asian so
basically you prefer
porn with an asian person in it than not
ready agree or disagree i'll give you a
second
i need way more he's writing the whole
speech over here yo
okay three i sent me way more jesus
two
show the camera i'm finished
oh wow is there an arm what's going on
what is it agree if i'm
on camera because i'm like dude
it's memories i i [ __ ] it
yeah have you seen joe's porn they're
really good wait what agreement
he's on his secret hard drive
joe's sex tapes are great i thought she
meant if you're like being filmed now
and that's your answer
okay so why did you three you guys right
here disagree
mainly because you said the man part it
wasn't
man or woman yeah i know it's asian does
it make you hornier
for me it's uh it doesn't matter if it
doesn't matter about the race
it's how big their dick is quality of
the porn performance-based performance
and if they're real estate agents or not
it was
what you keep telling me that you love
that [ __ ] i like the real estate part
but not
the white girl part you love that girl
white girl
i like the real estate one real estate
then why did you say that
at least this is the plot
this is not the genre i know but i know
you don't know genre
isn't this more like mockumentary or
documentary or something
or if they're peeing if the taxi is fake
or not yeah most of the asians don't
shave as well
yeah or like not as clear but the asian
american one's different see
when you're watching asian american porn
it's different from japanese
pictures that are like traveling and
doing things in weird places oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah those are very
important
you guys gotta check out chinese
homemade uh
amateur professional porn like it's kind
of like this new
like it's kind of like being an
influencer right like in
you know these days you got pornhub
where you have really hot couples
coming through with some [ __ ] and you
know china's really
upping their game in the porn game you
know they used to suck are they how do
you know that stuff
keep speaking on it i want to know more
i'm i'm a pretty good connor right the
link write the link
oh you got to search it on pornhub oh
okay we'll share some links
you gotta write in chinese china's
booming porn culture
china's booming yeah it's it's pretty
cool that stuff is good though
learn something new every day okay we're
moving on user generated content on
pornhub it's the members section not the
okay not the professionals
it's by the people for the people by the
people searchlight
section yeah by the people republic of
china okay ready
and koreans too i can't i can't i can't
sleep on them
they're they're crushing sleep with them
yeah and film it too
film it yeah okay moving on this one's a
loaded one all right
load them up i didn't write it i'm just
here as a puppet okay
i was embarrassed to be asian-american
when i was younger
wow we're about to reveal some uh
childhood trauma huh
are you ready you're ready oh wait i
whoa whoa
whoa we're on round three and you're
gonna do that
you're gonna beyonce the rest of the
[ __ ] group right now joseph
i didn't know we're good at counting
down okay ready
three two one reveal your answer
disagree agree i was i was
i wish i was black or mexican disagree
agree
disagree mostly okay let's talk about
yours why are you doing disagreement
because i was proud and then some you
know definitely some white
kids like just make fun of you and then
you don't know what to do
but then you're like still proud when
you go home just sometimes you're like
what
that's pretty tight what was yours i was
agree you were embarrassed i was
embarrassed when i was a young child
how many asian people were you're in
high school in europe well i was it was
mostly when i was like elementary school
like i was elementary school i was like
one of like
three maybe of the whole school of like
our grade
our grade um and i remember again i just
get picked on a lot
but also too it's like i remember when i
would watch like tv growing up and i
would think like this is how [ __ ] up
it is i used to think that like
if you wanted to be a good guy you had
to be like a white person or like a
black person or something
and then if you're if you're if you want
to be a bad guy you'd have to be like
some [ __ ]
a brown or yellow character yeah
literally anything else like an evil
villain
yeah like that have you ever watched
channel 18 well challenging
all the asian oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's the only challenge vietnamese
watch growing up is jay channel i was on
tv we could watch
but uh yeah like i felt that way when i
was growing up but as i got older i
started to realize i was like
that's [ __ ] white most people grow
out of it some people never do
yeah that's so sad uh yours was agree or
disagree disagree you disagree you were
always proud
no so i think i i was like i mean you
were always embarrassed no so
no we're not like when i true we did a
lot of shows and we went out to meet
a lot of the other asians that's when i
realized oh man like there's
this concept of being a minority um
i can see where they're coming from
because i grew up in cerritos and i
think i was just
really like i guess the not blessed but
um i guess advantaged in a way where
it's really really diverse
so it was already super diverse lots of
asians lots of
white hispanic everything you know and
so being in that group
it never felt anything was weird like we
had like
indians in the filipino club there's
asians and the skater groups there's
white guys with
bangs and asian gangs it was like super
like that like
asian people on the foot and uh in like
um the football team
so it just never felt like anyone was
weird
everyone was just a super diverse like
my even like the street that i grew up
on fellows in street shots and when they
grew up there
shout outs to the streets like everyone
was just it was just super diverse so
like i never felt weird or anything like
it just felt like everyone belonged last
time and i didn't know that there was
this like feeling of like us
versus them or whatever until later on
i'm like oh [ __ ] that's crazy there's
this
a different like with that one asian kid
in an entire class of whatever
i was like yeah i mean joe you felt it
right because you wanted to be
everything
else i didn't even know that i was asian
until people kept calling me chinese
yeah for real
and then i was like it was pointing
lampshades be like oh yeah it's your hat
and i was like what
damn the lampshade hey
somebody would say like china or
something they all the kids would look
yeah
right at me and then like it was i was
that
different like culturally until like i
really realized that growing up so you
brought your lunch i know and i brought
my lunch out yeah that's a real one
all the [ __ ] like i grew up with mostly
black and mexican kids right
and then um all the coolest stuff we
were into
like basketball hip hop everything it
was mainly
black culture like the rappers and
everyone that was cool like
michael jordan michael jackson everybody
right all the michaels
all the michaels yeah michael bolton you
know what i mean like all the
the real black peoples you know no i
think that i think that's that's why i
was like oh dude like
like to make it in life like man black
people have all the coolest [ __ ]
bro i just think the same that's so
crazy yeah [ __ ] and then for you
did you um feel like what he felt i i
disagree because
here's an interesting dick point of view
is that it's already easier
i grew up with like all asians all the
time like all the different
types of asians where'd you grow up san
gabriel oh i know how yeah
super asian so late
i think like the the craziest thing is
like we i was never
i never ran into anything that made me
feel like i wasn't proud to be asian
because so many asians have each other's
backs but
this is a weird thing if you grow up in
all asians your whole life
i think more than a white person can
make you feel embarrassed for being
asian
a korean person can make you feel
embarrassed for being filipino whoa
what does that mean i think that like
once you reduce the population to all
asian
there takes place a different caste
system yeah
very true very true that's the stuff
that i was running into
it was like the clicks of different
asians yeah they speak to you in spanish
the agents yeah
what are you doing here clean my house
yeah it's that thing of like then you
learn where
filipinos are in the social hierarchy
where are they not a good place put it
out put it out right now yeah wrinkles
right now based off of your younger
experiences
it's like this is like the uh i think
it's kind of more class based but then
we would be told that we're like the
mexicans of asians oh these are the best
i mean that's from that's coming from
you guys had swag
you guys are hard-working you guys are
[ __ ] amazing lovers like if you go to
like when i went to singapore
when i went to singapore for the first
time the very first time and uh in like
2005
and uh this dude was like hey what do
you think filipinos do out here in
singapore
i was like i don't know nurses and
doctors like everybody else and
do start laughing they sell oranges yeah
and he goes
bro out here they're either prostitutes
or construction workers and that's it
okay and i was like big diss dude
because that's the thing you don't
realize that like he thought that was so
funny to tell you
yeah he was just like you're gonna get a
kick out of it you're not gonna believe
this
but then it's like you you forget that
like man like aside from like
white people or black people or any
other people making asians feel like
that
yeah if it's all asians someone's gonna
feel like
within black people there's like there
is there is that hierarchy
any amount of people on any size island
find a way to divide it and you just
gotta cope with it or
i was talking the other day and he was
like oh i'm from malaysia and i was like
oh cool like my grandma's from malaysia
like and then my mom's from singapore
that's like the mexicans of the
southeast asia yeah pretty much and he
goes
singapore that's what he said i was like
whoa singapore oh man
nice to meet you and i was like i was i
was like friends with the guy
i talked i'm chummy with the guy and i
was like oh cool appreciate it
he was ill about the singapore part yeah
i was like oh interesting wow
singing what a generalized reaction but
you know what's funny is like
crazy someone's like like discriminating
you but they're disgruntled you're
you're you're someone's [ __ ] to someone
like all down the chain
unless your family is a world-class
illuminati banking family
everyone's a [ __ ] [ __ ] to somebody
exactly
yeah i'm a [ __ ] to all of you guys for
sure wait what
yeah i did that
you